hey mr wonderful here and welcome to
another
episode of ask mr wonderful now
this week as always has been brought to
you by
questions from the audience which i
think is the best way to do this
there are two that i found absolutely
fascinating kind of interrelated which i
think kicks us off into a
another but i hope to be very
interesting session
listen to this one this comes from
johnny devica
i'm a 15 year old student who aspires to
be an engineer someday
i've seen you appear on various tv shows
along with one of my personal favorites
shark tank one of mine too johnny i love
shark tank
you have been an inspiration for me for
a long time and i would it would be very
helpful if you would answer my question
i would like to know what was the
biggest factor that helped you achieve
success
any response would be greatly
appreciated well thank you johnny but
before we proceed
i want to read one from melissa kind of
along the same
genre but a little more specific because
she's been viewing some of the episodes
recently
melissa writes i watched your episode on
how you made your first million and i
also watched last week's show about the
five
common attributes of successful people
and i still feel ripped off
okay okay so you started a software
company in your basement
and sold it for 4.2 billion i get that
but you never explained what made your
company different from the tens of
thousands of other software companies
that started at the same time
what did you do differently what made it
so valuable
i have started my own business now and
i'm trying to learn everything i can to
avoid
failure if you really are mr wonderful
you will give it up
don't disappoint me okay melissa
and johnny melissa that's a little tough
love there
i don't think you should feel ripped off
it started you on your journey
to question and i think that's fantastic
but you raise a very valid point
what differentiated the learning company
from the thousands of other companies
who are trying to do the same thing
i wanted i want to talk about a concept
in life
and business and entrepreneurship
called pivoting in other words you set a
path for yourself
you have to i don't care what you're
doing in life you have a plan
you have an educational plan maybe
you've got a business plan you've got a
life plan
you've got a marriage plan you've got
whatever it's a plan you see yourself
three to five years out and you're
thinking about
who am i and what am i going to be and
how am i going to get there
and everybody should do that there's
nothing wrong with that
but sometimes you start down the road
and you find out it's not exactly what
you had planned
and you have to do something called
pivot
let me tell you a story the reason i
think this story is important
it points out in life the concept of
experience
and as you go down the road and you have
all these experiences
they go into your collective database
your memory and sometimes it's
really really important to pull from
that experience
when it comes time to pivot and make a
move and i'll give you this example
you know i finished undergrad college my
dad says to me environmental studies
psychology you're gonna starve to death
some of you've heard this story before
he said why don't you while you're you
have time and you've got decent marks go
and get a business degree
which i did so i went to do my mba
post-grad that's a two-year program in
those days and
you get a few months off in the summer
so i'm walking down the halls and
there's all these recruiters and i'm a
marketing guy
and i love the idea of apprenticeship of
learning something
i mean it's you know you're only going
to be working for 60 or 90 days
but what can you learn from that what
can you get you're not even working call
it an
internship or call it an apprenticeship
i love this because
it lets you immerse yourself into an
environment where you can just be a
sponge and
suck up as much as you can then get back
finish
college and move on with your life
towards your big goals
i'm walking down the hall and i see this
company called nabisco brands with a
brand called
miss mew cat food and they basically
were looking for somebody to expand the
product line
over a 90-day period in other words in
the pet food business
you need as many facings on the shelf as
you can get no different than any other
business the more
facings you have the more real estate
you have on the shelf
it's same online the more different
flavors you've got
the more presents you have when you're
pitching your product to somebody who's
going to buy it online
but in those days it was all retail and
so they're just saying look kid
we're looking for somebody that has
marketing grit
and can take our line from 21 flavors to
maybe 24 over a 90 day period
i said sounds good i'm in let's go
now what did i know about pet food
nothing
but listen it's a marketing problem and
i think i can learn quickly and i think
you can too
so the first day on the job i meet this
dutch guy who was my
boss basically he was a product manager
a portfolio manager or brand manager
and he says listen kid i'm going to take
you on a little journey today we're
going to go to the rendering plant where
we
make this cat food we're driving in the
car on the way there
and he says to me look i want you to
understand something about pet food
it's basically made from two engines
of protein i said what does that mean he
said i'll tell you
sea of japan tuna the underbelly
is one engine of protein we buy
millions of tons of that rendered tuna
or that
underbelly dark tuna that people don't
want to eat and then we add
bacon bits to it or maybe we add peas or
maybe some carrots or maybe some wheat
or whatever it is and we create a new
flavor
but the basic engine is and the protein
is the underbelly of the tuna and i said
i got it boss
you make different flavors from tuna to
expand the product line
and he said your job is to dream up some
flavors that cats are going to like you
know your whole testing facility
where we have all kinds of cats so you
can dream up your concoctions
work with the lab and see if the cats
like your stuff
and i said to him do the cats buy the
cat food
or does the pet owner buy the cat food
he said now you're thinking
we have to make it so the cats will eat
it so they'll buy it a second time
but basically you've got to make sure
that when they open the tin it smells
good and looks good
for the person who's buying it for the
cat you need both things to work the cat
has to like it
and the buyer has to buy it so you got
to come up with a flavor that looks
great on the label when you open it up
it's got to smell good and look good and
then when
fluffy looks at it and says oh i really
like this and fluffy eats it
fluffy being the cat now side story
the reason i say fluffy we received a
letter
from a woman in upstate new york who had
a cat that was 23 years
old now those of you who have cats for
pets
understand that's old
for a cat and she was wondering if
fluffy could
be featured on the miss mew
label as one of those you know cats with
with this
saying um you know this cat ate this
food and it's 23 years old pretty good
endorsement
except that the cat hadn't been eating
cat food it had actually been eating dog
food
a brand called dr ballard's dog food
also made by us in the bisco brands
so my boss said to me one of the things
you're going to be doing right out of
the gate is going
to check out this fluffy story i get
there
i meet the owner i meet fluffy
fluffy is 23 years old but also has no
hair
has no teeth is very very
very old and is leaking out of every
orifice a cat has
i don't mean that in a bad way i mean
it's just fact
and i said to the owner um
fluffy is is old
and she said yeah isn't it wonderful i
said well i really can't work with this
image because this cat
is and i'm trying to be delicate about
this i'm trying to say to her i think
the cat wants to move on
to cat heaven it's really looking rough
what i learned about that is it does
matter what you feed your cat
it does matter that they go at the right
balance but anyways
i was learning my way through the whole
cat world at this point
so back to the rendering plant sorry for
that diversion but i just remembered
that story and absolutely loved it
and so here we're at now and he's saying
to me for
the protein from the tuna is a whole set
of seafood-based flavors
you can work with that or you go to the
beef side where we mix
chicken faces beef lips renderings from
you know slaughterhouses this isn't
pretty stuff and if i recall what they
did is they put it in papaya juice
and it would kind of break it down into
into a pulp and they compress it
and that became the other engine so you
had two engines
you had the seafood engine you had the
chicken face beef engine and then you
added your flavors
your bacon bits or peas or carrots or
you know whatever you could dream up so
that that really hit me i thought to
myself i'd always thought you made all
these different things
to make these 24 flavors or whatever it
was
but really it's only two different
pastes
and then you get the inexpensive
flavorings and you dream up a new skew a
new product facing
i bring this story up because it ended
up being probably the most
important thing ever in my whole life
to pivot at the learning company to take
it from just
being an ordinary software company of
which there were tens of thousands
of them to the one that was worth 4.2
billion dollars a few years after it was
started
and here's how that manifested here's
the story
we were making software and i'll give
you an example
you see this this is rita rabbit this
cost
at that time 129 dollars full of
cd-rom discs because that's how things
were sold in those days and would cost
us about 850 to make
now we would sell it to retailers for 50
off so if it's 130 you're talking about
65 bucks
and we it made us nine to make it so the
margins are very very good and that was
really expensive because back in those
days the first
pcs coming out of boca raton were about
three thousand dollars
so you could get away with selling
software for prices like that but that
was all about to change because michael
dell
in his you know dorm room dreamt up a
new vision for computers that would make
them ubiquitous in every home in america
he wanted to drop the price at that time
below a thousand so knock two thirds off
the price
and that's what he did he was one of
those great entrepreneurs obviously
still around today
has grown a huge empire but he built it
around the idea of making computers
inexpensive for every family because
after all
this product is designed to advance
reading scores
and when you're going through grade
school you need reading and math scores
we also had a math version
to advance the child's ability to pass
the test to go on
into high school and then on to college
reading and math
are two engines remember engines
sea of japan tuna beef renderings
reading and math bing
one of those moments
it hit me like a ton of bricks i thought
to myself
we're competing like everybody else
writing from scratch software in reading
and math that's costing us
millions and millions of dollars every
time we come up with a new product
why don't we just standardize on two
separate
engines that we only develop and then we
add the flavors like maybe
we take big bird
we get a character we license it just
like rita rabbit we owned the rabbit
this is rita rabbit over here
that's a character it sits in the engine
why don't we license a whole
bunch of characters and we'll just
maintain
two development teams and we'll have two
engines
reading and math sea of japan tuna
beef rendering you get it now right and
i went to see my partners and i said
look
i had this experience back you know 10
years earlier
at a rendering plant where they made pet
food
and it was a multi-billion dollar
business with just two flavors basically
the two pace
why don't we do the same thing and cut
our development costs
dramatically i think we could save 12
percent maybe 15
right to the bottom line that's exactly
what we did
and boy did it work so what happened was
we started acquiring all of our and now
i'm giving you know melissa
you know and johnny basically
how this company became different from
all the others it was competing with
it was from that pivot moment that
change that i'd learned so many years
earlier just randomly in a pet food
rendering plant and and what i'm
suggesting to you is in life
keep these experiences because you never
know when you're gonna take it out
like an arrow out of your your quiver
and you know
and just use it as a tool that's the key
you want to have those arrows ready to
put into your crossbow or your bow and
arrow when you need them as i did that
day
because as soon as we figured that out
we said why don't we go acquire all of
our competitors
we can effectively almost overpay for
them and then drastically cut
everybody out of the business because
the business was growing so fast they
would just get new jobs right away
so we weren't worried about that we made
a very good point of giving them
tremendous counseling and finding people
so we would buy a company just keep the
10 developers
and give them the two math and reading
engines and come out with products
at a fraction of what they were spending
originally to develop it
that means our cost of capital went way
down
as our stock price went up and we
continued to use it as a currency
to buy more and more and more and more
companies
in fact we went on a spree to
consolidate the entire industry there
were so many companies doing the same
thing
that it made sense that somebody would
take the rendering strategy the two
engines
and put it all together and if you go
back online you'll see all the
controversy i remember the wall street
journal did a
an article one of our competitors called
broderbund said we know the difference
between
cat food and children's software well no
actually they didn't
that was the whole point and we we
bought them in a hostile acquisition
actually
and so they weren't able to stay
independent because we had grown so big
and controlled so much distribution that
we're able to take them
also do the same thing just keep their
products
and their developers and continue to
expand and that is actually
how the learning company ended up being
worth 4.2 billion dollars
because we figured out a pivot that we
learned from another industry
now there were some things that happened
along the way that i think are really
important too
that are great lessons learned there was
a big
conference in those days each year
called comdex
and all of the world's industry around
computers and software met in las vegas
for the con
comdex you know conference and
every company had a booth we had a booth
too and
i'll never forget this it was around the
time
when the first dell computers were about
to break
a thousand dollar price point 999
dollars
and i'm sitting in the booth with a
woman named kathleen baum who is one of
our marketing people
and along comes a buyer from a network
this is like 1995.
a buyer from a network called qvc
still exists i go on qvc all the time
it's a fantastic marketing tool
it reaches millions of people on live
televisions that buy consumer goods and
services a great way to test products
and he said to me listen you're selling
this software here
for 129 bucks and the first
999 dollar pc is coming out do you
would you consider bundling maybe a few
products together like maybe your your
key draw
product with your
form designer and maybe some of your
educational software together into one
offer let me stick in my head in the
middle here
for 29.95 i said what are you crazy
together this is like 400
worth of software he said no you're
crazy you don't get it
the world's about to change if the price
of a pc is dropping to 9.99 and maybe
lower
you got to get hip and the way to test
it is you got to check it out on our
network you can price it bundle together
and see how it goes and if it doesn't
work you stop doing it
you're not going to destroy your retail
multiple tier distribution because we're
selling direct to consumer
build a special version all bundled
together of your products
and let's let's test it out at one price
point
i looked at kathleen she looked at me
i said what do we got to lose let's
check it out
now the reason i bring this story up is
kathleen baum recently
found that tape and sent it to me now
you can see it
here's the two of us marketing software
on qvc
hi welcome back to the computer shop i'm
bob powers and i have two people that i
met
uh at comdex that's right while along
too long ago we've been trying to get
softkey onto qvc for a long time this is
kevin o'leary
president of softkey nice to meet you
down here is kathleen paul hi kathleen
hi nice to meet you kathleen's the
wizard
she has all of this under under control
what we're going to show you is actually
five of the finest programs you're going
to see in a package
and what is so nice about this is that
you get them as an exclusive package
one thing that you we can do here at qvc
if you're not a qvc viewer you'll have
no access to this soft key five pack
it's only thirty nine dollars and sixty
two cents
it's an eleven four ninety nine it
includes body works 4.0
key design center 3d time almanac 1995
the silver platter cookbook and the mpc
internet wizard
all in one package for under 40. this is
all cd-rom
as we weren't just successful it was a
sellout we blew out the numbers like
we couldn't even have dreamt in just
minutes and back in those days you were
on a rotating table or something
it was absolutely incredible
but that's not really what made it magic
during that airing somebody
in arkansas was watching it and that
somebody was a buyer at walmart
and shortly after that aired i got a
phone call from bentonville
headquarters of walmart and it was
basically like this mr o'leary
we want you to come down and talk to us
about the software business we're huge
in the music business
but we haven't done much in software yet
and we now are going to be selling a
computer
shortly for under 800 bucks
now walmart when they get into a sector
they get aggressive
and we would like to have a whole suite
of educational software and reference
software
so that our parents who are buying these
for the family
have plenty of offerings can you make it
down
and see me next week and i thought
hmm let me think about that the largest
retailer on earth wants to see me about
putting my software in their stores
no i'm going to push them off
that's not what happened i got down
there
real fast and in in those days and it's
probably still true today
they videotaped the meeting between the
buyer and the seller so you couldn't do
anything
that would breach any rules and they
tell you they're going to do that
i think it's fair and my buyer
and that's the great thing about walmart
they're really smart they don't leave
buyers in place for years and years they
move them through different product
categories
and my buyer had been i think it was in
fish tackle
and rubber boots for fishing fishing
supplies which are huge at walmart
i sit down with them we i think we have
a 40-minute meeting teed up
and i walk them through the whole world
of software and all the different
products and all the price points and
you know at that time
i was saying on special this would sell
for 9
99 and that i could probably give him a
great deal at 89 bucks
suggested retail price if he bought a
lot
and i'll never forget that moment he
looked at me and said
no no no if we're selling
computers for 8.99
and even 7.99 with speakers and a
monitor
we're thinking reader rabbit is 29.95
and i said i can't sell it to you for
29.95
he said no you're going to sell to me
for 14 bucks
i said sir with all due respect
the whole industry doesn't work on
margins like that there's nobody
in the world selling a software package
to you
for 14.95 that you're going to sell at
29.95
he said i think i can sell 12 million
packages
now that was a moment in time where i
had to make a decision because he had
told me beforehand if we didn't leave
with a deal
there were plenty of other software
companies waiting outside and maybe he
was bluffing maybe
he wasn't they were going to take up on
this opportunity
did i want to take a purchase order
potentially worth 12 million dollars
change the entire industry margins by
class
collapsing collapsing them 75 basically
did i want to take the entire industry
and collapse its gross margins
by 75 in one walmart sale
it would have caused chaos to take
software that was on deal at
you know normally sold at 129 and
sometimes at 99 and all of a sudden put
it out at 29
you'd have to be crazy to do that
what do you think i did i shook his hand
i said you're on now i knew when i
called my partners back at headquarters
that it was going to be a shitstorm
because the risk was horrific
imagine all the inventory we already had
in the channel all around the world we
were selling in 34 countries
that all of a sudden we drop our prices
that dramatically
but think of the volume if that 12
million was real
we went to see some of our biggest
investors the following week and i said
look i said yes to this
i think it's the right thing to do all
of us at you know the team is on board
we want to make this happen
we need massive manufacturing facilities
to pull this off
we're going to need every cd-rom stamper
on earth
to fill these orders it was one of those
pivots one of those moments one of those
crazy times of
either going to make our company very
very valuable
or we're going to crash and burn those
are the moments you have to experience
in your life as an entrepreneur
because they define who you are who the
company is and what the value is for
your shareholders
you have to take risks but isn't the
premise
doesn't it make sense if the price of
computers is collapsing
wouldn't you want to have lower price
commodity-based software
and we thought 29 was a low price well
we did that deal the reason that michael
jackson's
album bad was delayed two weeks is
because the learning company sucked up
all the capacity worldwide just to stamp
out
cd-roms for its orders at the new price
point that's a true story
i'm very proud of it i have a copy of
that album from that original press
loved it by the way but we basically
tied up every single stamp we could get
to fulfill all those orders and
everybody else
the price point in software did not stop
at 29.95
by the time that year was over we were
selling software at 12.99 to 19.95
and selling millions and millions
and millions of copies
that essentially is the story of what
made
the learning company so valuable and how
it was sold for that price it had so
much market share because it dropped
prices
and turned software into the commodity
it was
and because it had the expertise of
developing around
engines from the cat food days were able
to drive
a model that made sense we could put
controls on our r d
costs continue to launch products
quickly by just licensing characters
which we did
and launched thousands of skus
over two or three year period it was a
remarkable
pivot and it wasn't just me it was a
team the thing about successful
companies is the team
everybody understanding the path the
engine pivot that came from the cad food
business
but to implement and execute it took a
team of people
and we had tremendous talent doing it
and we just looked at our competitors in
the dust
they didn't they never caught up we
basically acquired most of them
and the industry of course changed again
when everything went online
but my point in this week's episode was
the concept of the pivot
the risks the pivot and seeing the
direction you need to go
even though it's risky in the case of
dropping the price of software and
working with every retailer around the
world to sell it
at a commodity price that every family
could afford that was a defining moment
for the learning company
and we had tremendous talent to pull it
off but i'm glad melissa you asked that
question because you're right i never
explained that
but that is essentially how it worked
and i think when i look at great
entrepreneurs today maybe you
even and johnny what will make you
successful is experience that you'll
take
and have those tools in your memory to
use when you have to make your pivot
great entrepreneurs do that all the time
don't let a crisis ever be wasted you
learn something from it
and then you move forward because you
might not use it that day
but you're going to use it one day and
it's going to be tremendously valuable
for you
that is the story of the learning
company and it all started with fluffy
that's why i love the fluffy the cat
story it ends up
fluffy helped us made us worth over four
billion dollars thank you fluffy
wherever you are in cat heaven
i appreciate you unless you're still
alive but i don't think that's the case
everybody i really enjoyed it thank you
for the questions and i will see you
next week now speaking about pivoting
imagine you're involved in the wedding
industry
there hasn't been a wedding in months
nobody's renting halls nobody's buying
flowers nobody's renting carpets
nobody's having big dinner parties
that's all shut down
these are entrepreneurs that want to
survive i've invested in many of them so
they have to pivot
now you know me i like to get involved
with my entrepreneurs i like to help
i like to bring in my social media
platforms to see if we can reduce
customer acquisition costs together and
i like innovation i like
ideas so sarah mongolis the ceo of honey
fund said to me
why don't we do a virtual wedding to
promote the business
why don't we actually marry people
online now that's a crazy chicken idea
and guess what there's all kinds of
people that still want to get married
they want to get on with their lives
they want to start a family
they can't wait for covet to set us free
they've got to work within the confines
of what this pandemic has done to large
and small businesses alike
and that's all about innovation and
pivoting so check this out
yup i got ordained and i married this
wonderful couple
that's innovation that's business
and that my friends is a pivot
okay everybody take your places
we gathered here today surrounded by the
beauty of creation
and nurtured by the sights and sounds of
nature to celebrate the wedding
of ian and erica before we begin the
vows
erica would like to share something with
you ian i guess i didn't really know
what i was getting into when i signed up
to date a police officer
but what i've learned is although it's
incredibly hard to watch you go through
what you go through
i will always be here for you through
thick and thin
i'm gonna love you babe do you ian
matthew cochran take erica
kathleen brower to be your wife i do do
you
erica kathleen brower take ian matthew
cochran to be your husband
i do and by the power vested in me
i now pronounce you husband and wife
congratulations guys